Blair you are from HR here at Turner I
am that's terrific
it's tell me what's going on with you
guys I have a lot of issues he tells
people that I floated to this country in
a basket and that found me in a push and
that I learned how to speak English by
watching reruns of dynasty I said that
once to a Rolling Stone reporter yes
then it got printed in Rolling Stone
magazine and how did that make you feel
it didn't make me feel good he has
knocked food out of my hand on more than
one occasion she'll be having a cook and
be like oh my god these cookies in the
green room are so good and she'll be
holding it up just perfect like perfect
tight like this and I'll go and knock
the cookie and sometimes it really goes
flying and if there are people around
they all laugh because they have to
because I'm the boss it's hot in here
like if we're out at a store or
something running an errand he'll tell
the workers you better watch out for her
cuz she steals and that must that must
really hurt your feelings we went to
this store at this shop for glasses for
me and you were looking around at all
the cases on your own keep an eye out
for this one she's got sticky
but do you understand how that might
makes us feel like a criminal thank you
is it my turn
yes you team Lee call me a dick a
monster yeah you say that I'm Irish so
all I do is eat potatoes beautiful lie
which is she says I'll ask for something
on the phone and I say can you do that
and she'll say yes and she hangs up and
then it goes right out of her head and
that happens a lot if I forget a lot so
how do we how do we resolve that maybe
less edibles at night Oh
outside of the workplace thank you for
the matter challenge inside the wall she
chokes him like Scooby Snacks and I'll
tell you something else
what if outside the office behavior
affects inside the office behavior
that's a different story
yeah and that's my story because I think
sometimes you are so whacked out on your
wacky tabacky your chewy go Louise is I
think the kids column there are human
hominids your jub jubs in gelato is your
bed actually I think that there is a
mental block I have about helping him
because um does he say to wait wait wait
this was huge and you jumped in you
jumped in she has a mental block against
helping me she's my assistant
you have a mental block against
assisting me let's understand why let's
understand why I think some positive
reinforcement happy nice and also he'd
be great if he stopped being so
passive-aggressive all the time I'm not
sure about a girl
these are slanders these are libels I am
NOT a passive-aggressive man I am but a
man he goes into character when he
doesn't want to address reality do you
does too many bits do you see the bits
that he this never stopped it never but
you have bits are never ending you do
work for a comedian an artist any
communication target one of the great
comedians oh my god you work for a
comedian
how many comedians right now does TBS
have oh right
the Impractical Jokers we talked about
his neediness - yeah before we get to
that well it's always the Impractical
Jokers
those Wang's from Staten Island they get
all the glory
I'm sorry fellas I didn't mean to go
after you I knew you all grew up on a
landfill you're doing the best you can I
hope they have some good tricks that
they can play we'll see on that
orphanage
go in there and tell those kids that we
found a father for them sometimes
they'll come up and he'll be like hey
stupid cult and it says it's you get it
if I just said you were stupid
I agreed that's not funny and that's
abusive but if I tell you that you got a
phone call and you're like oh really and
I go yeah a stupid sound line that is
you which meaning by implication that's
a home run that's a home run that it's
like he ever seen the movie that natural
when when Robert Redford hits that ball
and hits it you know he goes out of the
park it hits the lights at night and
they explode and I'm just rounding the
bases in slow motion that just been
slowly going around the bases and
showering down sparks but do you know
that most people do have feelings no
idea I have feelings what why don't we
talk about this before I tell you all
the time I tell you to stop you know
telling people I steal babies from the
marketplace you've never been tempted to
steal a baby at the marketplace
I think the stealing theme keeps coming
up here why does this stick to you this
stealing thing I mean I used to steal
you used to steal what did I was totally
kidding around this is a breakthrough
I stole a little sticker book from
Sanrio oh heck oh I stole skittles from
Blockbuster I stole ass addictive dumb
ones from the market I stole a bracelet
from Express
I stole another bracelet from Express
Hat someone told me to return it and I
did and then I I stole a headband from
Urban Outfitters once I stole a hat okay
and this
this is a crime spree that the hillside
strangler would envy here we are on his
desk nothing sets it to the tone like
this sign okay right here when they come
in I've done so much for Sonnen all I
ask in return is little things like this
oh hey Sonu what's going on cookies
that's all I'm asking for in return that
gives me so much joy what yeah Selita
look cookie still I'm glad that you got
joy it was you get that weird how this
works for us it's sick it's wrong
very little accomplished very very
little yeah it's insanity and it should
be stopped it's your job to stop it but
you won't stop it what would you like me
to fire you I think we should both be
fired well this is great you did this I
didn't do it you did it I'm gonna get a
job at a Burger King and you're gonna be
my assistant I crush it at Burger King
[Applause]